a dance contest hey how about you and i
entering the contest kelly
we could win it all win with you
your feet need training wheels winning
losing
dancing's supposed to be fun well it
will be fun if kelly dances with me well
gee guys i mean i'd love to be partners
with both of you
why don't you just go with the best
dancer
hit it
[Music]
[Applause]
right in the middle of wrestling
practice it dawns on me hey
i owe zach 20 bucks but i'm broke so i
came over here to work it off what
you don't owe me anything man what a guy
thanks preppy butt
i insist look this isn't a good time oh
it's perfect
you two won't even know i'm here
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
sorry was that paper important
no it's just my homework with every
answer on it
i'm really sorry about that zach but hey
don't worry i've got the chapter on
icebergs and glaciers down
cold then i will do just fine once you
go clean the basements
sure
oh come on zach slater feels bad let him
help
but no no no no i don't want to
interfere with your study date
you won't interfere three minds are
better than two
have a seat well okay if you insist
daddy ac is the star athlete that is
high school
really do you play polo young men
no but i have a lot of those shirts
so tell me sir is lichtenberg a big
country
it's not huge i have uh three million
subjects
yeah i only have five subjects
yeah math english history
so how about them dodgers huh relax i
see just be yourself
i'm trying tell me about your father ac
what does he do oh my dad oh well he's
in the army he's a major
i mean uh colonel oh i i mean a general
well which one is he he's all of them a
major penalty
that's quite impressive thank goodness
[Applause]
mom oh just your average movie queen
turned united state senator
let's find the family tree you have
there hey that's only one limb
let me tell you about my grandfather who
owned most of california
football tickets for the raiders and
they only cost me a hundred dollars
but i have tickets to the ballet great
who wants to see a bunch of barbarians
kick each other's butt anyway
you mean you like the ballet oh what
does this tell you
[Applause]
oh
[Music]
hey braby there she is
hey you know julia yeah i know joanna
she's a girl i've been telling you about
no no no no she's the girl i've been
telling you about
hey slater yes you went into the senior
party yet
no no
joanna would you like to go to the
senior kickoff party with me
gosh i don't know what to say i mean i'm
flattered
i've never been asked out by two guys
before at least not
simultaneously probably i should think
about it a little oh
absolutely take your time oh just go
right ahead think away
mind you for joining me we're a great
company sure
he's a little clumsy
all right now already come on give me a
nosy
slater that was great hey well i'll give
you a nosy too
that was a great trick slater how'd you
get him to do that well screech it took
a lot of patience
and a lot of flies do you mind i'm
eating
hey you wanna hold him preppy no thanks
i'd prefer holding something
cute and female oh buy a poodle okay
i think he's cute how'd you end up with
a chameleon as a pet anyway
well actually artie found me when my dad
was stationed in the philippines
since then we've been through 14 schools
together
he's the only friend i haven't had to
say goodbye to so why don't you two go
steady
screech you love animals how about
watching arty for me while i go to san
diego this weekend
will you really trust me to chameleon
sit well i trust anyone who names all
the ants on his ant farm
naming them was easy it's remembering
their birthdays that's tough
is already here on any kind of special
diet nah
just flies bugs anything you'd find
stuck to the windshield of a car
that's it
don't forget artie's chew toy
oh cute come on let's go catch him some
dinner
[Music]
hey zach last night at the movies you
went too far
just helped a mother get together with
her son what's so wrong about that
wrecking my date with joanna wasn't
funny
oh like it was funny wrecking my study
date the night before
hey you started it man making me look
like a jerk at the max
well that's what you are what did you
say
you heard me you get out on my face but
what if i don't
punk then i'll just have to make you
punk
[Applause]
[Music]
hey could you show me that shot again
[Music]
christina
oh terrific shot han
father hello
este i would like you to meet my father
the king of lichtenberg
uh you mean he's then that means you're
oh boy hi be with you in a second
christina you weren't kidding you really
are a princess
does it matter well yeah i mean
no i'm glad it usually scares guys off
that's why i didn't tell you at first
is uh everything okay oh everything's
great
oh yeah great your highness ship is that
what you call him
no i call him father so
can you give my daughter any competition
she is tough to be
she puts around the palace all day yo i
bet that moat's a real water hazard
let's see don't be nervous me
i'm not nervous excuse me
watch this
all right meet it hand them over
don't talk about his dog
now let's see how you do with someone
your own size huh
[Applause]
you were terrific but i thought you were
gonna quit wrestling
and when my quiche blew up and i
realized hey
i didn't care i'm just a kid i don't
need a career right now
yeah if we feel the same way we'll worry
about it next year
now that we see her lying there we dorks
admit we've been unfair if this evil
spell your kiss unlocks let's flip the
cookie and don our own socks
dork number five i gotta disagree if you
want snow white alive
don't look at me zack that's not in the
script oh to make her applause
accelerate she needs a kiss from dork
number eight it's true the prince is
just a friend but studly for me
is the living end
[Applause]
you are miss dudley and not the prince
now that we've kissed are you convinced
uh uh well at first i didn't like
all of this drama but now i trust you so
kiss me mama
[Applause]
baba
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Applause]
ah
[Music]
[Music]
my
[Applause]
hey hey what are you guys doing here
watching you dance bubba
come on you guys got to get out of here
hi samuel
i really loved your dancing oh yes
we loved how you all moved oh yes right
girls
come on guys come on
looks like the king is dead
you